hello everyone in this video I'll be
talking about the second messengers so
in any signalling scheme that you have
came across so the basic signalling
scheme would be the signal reception by
a receptor and conveying that signal
into the downstream headquarters which
is the nucleus and in the middle of that
there are several middle mats these
middleman's
are actually second messenger one key
aspect of these second messengers is
that they kind of amplify the signal so
we would take the example of our
well-known g-protein couple signaling
let's say here the red ligand has bind
to the GPCR and as a result it allows
activation of several g alpha subunits
and several G of a subunit can in turn
go and activate several admit cyclase
enzymes
once many adenine it cyclers enzymes are
activated several rounds of cyclic GMP
production would be there when several
rounds of cyclic GMP production is there
several protein kinase a molecules could
be activated and its catalytic subunit
can in turn go to the nucleus and at
several level the signal could get
amplified so the signal amplification is
a very important aspect when it comes to
the second messengers and due to the
second messenger signal is amplified
many of the cases
moreover the second messengers give us
more flexibility in the signaling system
or other terms it gives more regular
bility so the second messengers kind of
work like a transistor to take the work
like an amplifier to take the signal
from the outside and kind of amplify
that and send it to the nucleus so this
is how second messengers are so
important so in this video we will be
talking about several popular second
messenger and how they're involved in
cell signaling pathways so first let's
talk about calcium as a second messenger
now calcium is always important for
physio
logical purposes and it was discovered
by Sidney ringer and in 1880 s Sidney
ringer was trying to generate
composition of several artificial buffer
which can make a isolated heart beating
but all his experiments were failed
until one day when he suddenly used tap
water do we make the buffer instead of
distilled water and he saw magically the
heart started beating now he was like
surprised and later it was found that
London tap water was as heavily
contaminated by the salts of calcium
from that time this solution was known
as finger solution and people knew that
calcium is very important molecules in
terms of physiological aspect now
calcium is literally important for
several different cellular aspect
starting from muscle contraction
secretion metabolism fertilization
neuronal plasticity cell division
phagocytosis cell motility and many many
more so it turns out the level of
calcium inside a neuron can give rise to
different plastic outcome so the
plasticity or the flexibility in the
neuronal output could be different
depending upon the different level of
calcium calcium dynamics could range
from millisecond to seconds to minutes
or several times several days and
depending upon the level of calcium and
the magnitude of the calcium the outcome
of the plastic response is totally
different now in a cellular aspect
calcium cyclic AMP et8 cyclic AMP pip3
DG all these are second messenger
molecules so in a GQ signaling format
upon ligand binding the GQ gets
activated and the GQ activates
phospholipase c and the phosphor like
this c is a phospholipid so it can break
down for phospholipids in the membrane
and one such breakdown product of the
phospholipid is a nose
triphosphate the in acetyl triphosphate
can then migrate to the neutral ER and
on the ER there are several IP three
receptors now IP 3 receptors bind to IP
3 and as a result it allows the stored
calcium inside the endoplasmic reticulum
to be released in the cytosol now once
in the cytosol calcium can perform many
functions and the calcium in some in
calcium increasing the cytosol is
detected by several particular sensor
molecules which are basically Caltech
calmodulin calmodulin has four calcium
binding domains which can sense the
sudden increase in the level of calcium
and car modeling can interact with
several different modulators to give
different outcomes in one of the cases
car modeling can activate several
phosphatases so phosphorus these
phosphatase can allow a nuclear
transcription factor to be mobilized to
the nucleus and give rise to
transcription so the calcium increase
has could could have different different
outcome depending upon the context and
which cell it is so that is how calcium
is very important like a second
messenger cyclic EMP is one of the
earliest discovered second messenger
among all those system but what cyclic
AMP II does is like whenever is signal
is receptive the signal is amplified and
goes to the nucleus so the cyclic AMP II
is different from normal ATP ATP cannot
be used as a psychic second messenger
right because the cell would be too much
confused about the ATP because several
metabolic processes also create ATP so
if cell use ATP as a second messenger
system so it would be very hard for the
cell to decode the message now cyclic
GMP is a cyclic variant of ATP that is
why it is unique and can be work can be
used as a second messenger system
it has been seen that neural activity
can lead to increase in cyclic EMP and
this is correlated with memory storage
in fact Eric Kandel has shown that
conversion of the short-term memory to
long-term memory is involved long-term
memory involves cyclic EMP elevation and
mobilization of the protein kinase a
into the nucleus and thereby gene
transcription programs now it has been
also seen the mutants where cyclic AMP
reproduction is hampered the fly'
mutants they're learning index decreased
dramatically so somehow cyclic AMP is
important in all these learning and
memory all these physiological processes
now how did scientists figure it out
that cyclic Amb works like a second
messenger so all the work goes to our
Sutherland all Sutherland received his
Nobel Prize in 1971 in Physiology and
medicine for his discoveries of
mechanisms of hormone action so he
mainly showed that the action of
epinephrine now around 16 1960 s he
showed that how cyclic adenosine
monophosphate or cyclic GMP serves as a
secondary messenger within the cell so
he started his work in the lab of Carl
and Gertie Cory I mean the famous couple
who discovered the Cori cycle and he was
looking at the role of epinephrine on
glycogen breakdown into glucose molecule
so what the experiment he was doing is
taking out the rat liver so the that
that lever was smashed homogenized and
to fraction was determined a cytoplasmic
fraction which would have glycogen
phosphorylase the terminal exam that
degrades glycogen into glucose and the
membrane fraction would essentially have
the epinephrine receptors so he
separated
these two fractions by centrifugation
now the membrane fraction which should
obtain we should contain the epinephrine
receptors he added epinephrine to that
fraction so now if epinephrine has give
rise to any kind of diffusible substrate
substrate then a filtrate of this
solution might be able to activate the
enzyme right now when now he took the
filtrate of the activated membrane
fraction and added that into the
cytoplasmic fraction which has the
glycogen phosphorylase now after adding
he has seen that the activity of the
phosphor Eilis has increased
dramatically than the before that allows
him to conclude this amplification of
the phosphorylase activity is due to any
soluble substances and later it was
discovered this soluble substances is
nothing but cyclic a MP a cyclic
variation of ATP now we know that
adrenaline in a g-protein coupled
receptor signaling pathway give rise to
cycle KMP and that cyclic a MP in turns
activates protein kinase a protein
kinase a actually activate phosphorylase
kinase and phosphorylase kinase is the
key activator which phosphor i which
actually phosphorylate and activate
phosphorylase and this phosphor i'll is
enzyme is the important enzyme in the
terminal step of glycogenolysis and that
is why now we understand why adding like
adding that epinephrine activated
membrane fraction could increase
phosphorylase activity and it is because
of the cyclic AMP ii which activated
protein kinase a so that is how the
mystery of the cyclic AMP II was
discovered apart from cyclic GMP cyclic
version of GMP could also work like a
second messenger it turns out people had
a very weird observation when the
directly inject acetylcholine into the
mass
the muscle contraction happens but
whenever they injected the nearby blood
vessels they have seen instead of
constriction there is a dilation of the
muscle and inquest of understanding this
for now weird phenomena they found our
that in the blood vessel there
estelle : receptors which are basically
g-protein coupled receptors and whenever
we add acetylcholine to the blood
vessels it ultimately gives rise to
phospholipase c activation and calcium
elevation into the cytoplasm which
ultimately the calcium increase converts
l-arginine to citrulline and produce
nitric oxide this nitric oxide in turns
acts upon nearby muscles this nitric
oxide can be detected by a detector
which is actually ultimately which can
convert cyclic GMP formation from the
gtp now the cyclic GMP which is also
very different from gtp can do several
tasks cyclic GMP can bind to protein
kinase G now protein kinase G is an
important factor protein kinase g can
prevent the myosin actin cross bridge
from formation and thereby it allows the
relaxation of muscle and that is how now
it is explained that how cyclic GMP can
work like a second messenger and how
smooth muscle relaxation up an
acetylcholine injection to the nearby
blood vessels could be explained so this
is how second messengers are so
important in signal transduction
pathways I hope you enjoyed this video
if you liked this video give it a thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you